how's it going bros my name is welcome
to another episode where we're going to
play Photoshop what the [ __ ] that I just
[ __ ] say alright alright alright so I
took a bunch of pictures of myself
fitbit.fitbit bit baby why am i enjoying
this this is not the video so we're
gonna Photoshop these no god I can't
stop any attempts to create the weirdest
picture on the Internet let's start by
just [ __ ] stretching out this [ __ ]
looks so natural now to make it look
super ultra realistic reading the eye oh
my god
this is legit [ __ ] terrifying
what have I done so yeah if you bros
want to do that one it's fairly easy
easy easy the--to let's move on to the
next picture okay so we have this
picture now we're gonna put my eye there
why I don't know it's the monster from
Pan's Labyrinth if you've seen it you
see that as a great film you should Shi
watch it and [ __ ]
god is so disgusting I get upset when
stuff is this is disgusting
don't you get pissed you off oh my god
makes me angry [ __ ] yeah thing just
[ __ ] about oh my god it's so
disgusting I can't oh oh god [ __ ] me I'm
out of there [ __ ] hell right okay let's
do this tongue one look guys it looks
like my tongue is super long hey well
well it starts you know it's a fun
little trick you know you can try it
with your yo me with your family babe
what's that we have time for one more
what's that it looks like I haven't
washed my hair for 50 days what was the
idea behind these pills I don't even
remember let's take away the eyes
nothing that ugly deserves to live
yes oh so tired what the [ __ ] am I doing
with my life
hey alright first let's review what we
did today we did the stretchy man phase
rubber [ __ ] oh god this one oh my god I
said I can't get over how disgusting
this one [ __ ] is and we did lower
Rupert sorry about this video bros I
will try and have more time to make
videos tomorrow it is it is hard thing
but I hope you enjoyed it not none of
the less I will see you as always and
stay awesome brush wow he looks so
animated
kawaii karin-sama